all right if you've been thinking about
selling your home now might be the time
as inventory levels around the valley
have dropped significantly here to talk
more about that Bob Hamrick CEO of
Coldwell Banker premier Realty the
sponsors of this segment uh we are back
to the times Bob of multiple offers for
a property almost the moment it's listed
it's so interesting Kendall we didn't
expect it to be coming back this quickly
we went basically from a seller's market
to a buyer's market back to a seller's
market in less than a year and that
means people will have buyers for the
home but there are still things that
people can do to increase the value of
the home absolutely we we instituted a
real vitalized program just a few months
ago it has been very very well received
helping sellers put more money in their
pocket by fixing up the home at no cost
to them until they sell the home and so
we're able to fix it up and get it
really competitive for the marketplace
it's a great idea because a lot of
people want to sell their home and they
they do want to make it look as nice as
possible but might not have the funds
available to do everything that's needed
the funds or even the skills and and we
just cause it to be very very convenient
so we know what to do we know how to do
it and we advance the dollars to make it
happen so even at a time when you're
saying it's a seller's market and
they're going to be multiple offers it's
still important to do everything you can
to make your house look as presentable
as possible condition is still one of
the key features to get a property sold
price is important but condition is
critical and condition causes a home to
sell for the highest price possible
talking about price is what's been
interesting is even with the lower
inventory prices have not spiked anymore
at least not significantly not yet 425
000 has been the number since December
each month we've ended the month at 425
000 but we are seeing signs that that
has that is the bottom and we're
starting to see signs that that price
will probably accelerate people trying
to time the market always a difficult
thing to do very difficult all right so
let's say you're on the buying side and
you're one of 15 people to make an offer
on a house other than making an
outlandish offer how do you get yours to
stand apart from others well there's
there's a lot of ways to do that being
able to have a great relationship or
develop a race relationship with that
other agent the listing agent because
the listing agent knows what's most
important to that seller so what we do
is try to develop that relationship ask
the right questions and make a
competitive offer on what's best for the
seller finally what are some key
mistakes either as a buyer or a seller
that people may make on their own
sometimes well pricing is as much as the
market is strong or getting stronger
it's still you have to price the
property competitively to get the
attention so I think that's one thing
and then on the buy side buyers don't
realize that the market has come back in
a pretty significant way so they're
trying to make offers that are too low
in a competitive market they're not
going to win yeah not a good time to try
to lowball somebody no all right Bob
always good to have you here appreciate
the Insight very much we want to thank
Coldwell Banker premier Realty for
sponsoring this segment you can call
them at that phone number on the screen
725-234 or 2277 or visit
realvitalizelv.com we'll be right back
[Music]